a million people are expected to attend
it features 552 players from 24
countries there's 30 million dollars
prize money it's being hosted in France
right now and being shown on the BBC is
the excitement mounting yes or would you
prefer Nick to spend the evening washing
your hair than watching the women's
football World Cup as I thought the
purse is a mere seven and a half percent
of the man's tournament men's tournament
in 2018 but the money isn't the main
problem it's awareness and attitude
panel I am part of the problem have I
ever watched women's football no apart
from a few clips on YouTube in
preparation for this our national team
could bring football home but still
women's team sports never get the
eyeballs or the investment or the media
interest that men's games do this year
the lionesses could win the World Cup
but how will we make anyone sit up and
pay attention
bands football women's football which is
the better there's only one way to find
out it's the battle of the sexes so we
need you to grade Rach pull on your
boots pull on your socks and let's cross
the sky sports legend in the glorious
sunlit surroundings Nick Powell over to
you
hello and welcome to the prestigious
soccer am stadium for the ultimate test
of footballing prowess the pledge
penalty shootout in these glorious
footballing conditions it is youth
versus experience it is brain against
broad and yes man against woman the
theme some fantastic skills on display
already and the crowd can't wait to see
what these do have in store let's meet
the players named Rachel left back in
the dressing room Johnson age Phil over
21 team shades UK United and our
position she's a superstar named Greg
fast and furious dyke age from the Queen
team Chelsea pensioners FC and his
position in goal for the big occasion
the pledge is fat cat lawyer Matt for
cat McKenzie so here we go and it is
Rachel Johnson to go first
McKenzie is ready disappointment here is
Dyke here he goes birdies copycat
football is nil nil and Rachel Johnson a
chance to take the lead this could be
the one that wins the pledge penalty
shootouts how about that and the
pressure now is on dyke the experience
can he do it straight this is the chance
to show that he's still got it up
yes tremendous out of just remind simple
numbers this is I wish the girls nothing
but luck I hope they win it would be
great you're right I'm afraid I'm not
watching it hasn't broken through
probably my fault I might argue about
some marketing just hasn't resonated
with it but I also say this and I find
it fascinating this if you look at I
like that football as I told you at the
weekend when the big teams play Old
Trafford Manchester United you probably
at either side of 60,000 people
Chelsea absolutely packed out 40 50
thousand the same with the Emirates at
Arsenal Leicester City it was packed out
just under 40,000 you will have the
biggest girls game women's game in the
Premiership and during that 1,500 2,000
people and that is the reality so the
breakthrough in researching this topic I
just I learnt about the 1971 Women's
World Cup in Mexico in which the England
team not then called the lionesses I
don't think were playing and they were
playing to cry to 110,000 in Mexico
admittedly this was in 71 it had country
it had absolutely no support from the FA
and you know
and they have they have done pretty well
in the last five six seven years and
it's quite interesting this is grown
I've got a figure it's something like
this 1774 new women's and girls teams
were registered last year now that's at
a time when men's leagues not boys teams
with men's teams are in decline
there's a woman running Baroness sue
Campbell who is the most effective
person I've ever seen in getting money
out of the organization she is and she
is pouring money into women's football
and the results don't get paid so you
might not be attracting the people that
you need to attract but you know what
you just said before I think you know I
look at those woman and I'm full of I
mean and at their dedication the hard
work how bloomin good they are and you
know you talked about the FAA banning of
long time when a football was around in
the 1800's and women I think it's a bit
of a false comparison I think we can't
compare women's football to men's
football because of the fact that it was
banned for 50 years we're starting so
behind and actually if you look at how
quickly it's become something that young
people are excited by I think that it's
moving in the right direction and yes in
terms of prize money there's a huge
difference between men and women so in
2018 the merlyn's World Cup total prize
money was 400 million dollars and
following year for women it was 30
million dollars and believe it or not I
don't actually have a problem with it
because if you look at how established
men's football is of course you're gonna
have this discrepancy but if we win the
World Cup I mean they are pitiful women
footballers get a thousand pounds a
month men football get hundreds about
thousand pounds
is the BBC playing it on people she want
to be a suit - yeah playing
international football if you look at
the viewing first in that it was an
average of 4.6 million and it's a peak
of more than 6 million that's not a fair
comparison because one is for him to err
worked out that actually they need a mix
between pay because people in the ball
here because I've really enjoyed today
because not only being able to quiz you
about your time at the BBC TV license do
you worry of course chairman of the FA
and I'd like you great to take part in
my little test we're going to show you
now three players three England players
who played for England during your time
can you left-to-right identify those
three that will be Jordan Henderson what
about in the middle would be John stones
you were the chairman why should you
know but now of course I know you will
Trump all three because these are the
women who played for England during your
time as chairman of the FA are in the
2019 World Cup squad because you know of
course it's from left to right Karen
Bardsley Jill Scott and of course it's
Fran Frannie curtly come on everybody
knows that you knew that because you say
that it's very hard for fans to know who
these people are and this little girl
who were going to hear she wrote a
letter to Tesco salesman because she
wanted to collect World Cups and she
went into her local superstore and there
were men stickers available but not
women so let's have a look at amis
letter in complaint about this which
ends I'm angry I am very very very very
very angry can you imagine
deciding you're going to go in and fill
your World Cup sticker with stickers of
your heroines your sporting heroines and
these pioneers on the pitch Sainsbury
said it is selling the Women's World Cup
stickers in the same number of stores as
the men's while Tesco said they were
excited about the Women's World Cup
apologized to me for not stocking the
stickers in her local store but said
they were available at their one-stop
convenience the problem is one result I
think it was US v Thailand but 13 nil
couldn't defend the goal I think we
should narrow the goal okay and grow the
women just rest now coming up here on
I'm telling you why I won't be joining
in with the losers in
[Music]